hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the Dutch Women's
Championship uh 2022 sorry about that
says 2021 on my interface the last video
was 2021 so I guess I forgot to update
it uh just give me a second there uh
there we go all right so Dutch Women's
Championship 2022 and I saw this um on
Twitter and I I decided to check out the
game the position was very interesting
and I I I I couldn't realize immediately
how how the position could happen so
quickly in the game it's like the game
is wrapped up pretty much in 10 moves uh
but uh you know you you you will see
it's really awesome you guys will have a
very nice pause the video moment uh and
uh the game is between uh two Dutch
players uh Mikey Catman and Anna Maria
Kazarian sorry if I'm mispronouncing
that I almost uh you know almost
exclusively I I always butcher Dutch
names
um uh so let's check it out and one
thing I wanted to apologize yesterday
during the stream during the military ex
Christmas Arena which was won by
norderbeck yakubov so congratulations on
that I said that uh maybe I'm not sure
that maybe not Rebecca dusatro will not
be defending his title as the world
rapid champion because I've heard uh
somewhere on Twitter someone was
discussing this it is not true he is
confirmed that he will play in the world
rapid championship and will defend will
try to defend his title so sorry about
that now getting to the game let's check
it out really an awesome one so uh Mike
with the white pieces opens with E4 we
have E6 anime goes for the French
defense uh we have D4 D5 and now Bishop
to D3 going for the schlechta variation
against the French and uh regarding
Schleich that we haven't really
discussed him all that much on the
channel uh but there's a really really
interesting story and it doesn't take
long I'm just going to share it with you
so he played in in 1910 he played the
World Chess Championship match against
none other than Emmanuel laskar and he
was leading up up to the last game it
was the 10 game games were being played
and going into game 10 he was leading
and he only needed a draw to actually
win the match but he went uh for an
all-out attack with the black pieces and
then lost in the end uh Alaska equalized
the match and which means that he was to
retain the title but the question is and
the the this is something that is being
discussed I believe still actively I
don't I don't think anyone knows if this
is actually through a true maybe some
chess historians do that there was a
clause uh that schleichten needed to win
by a two-point margin to actually take
the title away from Lasker and that's
why he went for such an old attack in
the final game even though he was
leading the match I have really weird
stuff but uh at one point we will
probably do Alaska Saga and then we're
gonna investigate it a little bit deeper
but okay this is the select a variation
uh C5 now uh makes sense that you always
play this against the French uh when
playing the French you want to attack
white strong Center e can't Preston D5
Queen captures on D5 and not Knight the
C3 and this is where the fun really
Starts Here exclusively you go back
Queen to d8 but in the game anima
decided to try and snatch the pawn she
played Queen captors on D4 and this
means that black will now be on the
defensive and I don't know maybe on the
absolute highest level this is already a
loss for black but it's not going to be
easy even if it's not so Knights the B5
attacks the queen and threatens Knight
the C7 check to pick up the rokanae so
of course you have to bring the queen
back now Queen to d8 and now Bishop to
F4 developing with Tempo now the threat
again remains Knight to C7 check so
Knight to A6 only move that defends the
C7 square and now Queen to E2 developing
the queen and making room for a nice
Queen side Castle which will also come
with Tempo sort of a half a Tempo an
x-ray Tempo if you will as the black
queen will share the the file with the
Rook so Knight to F6 and now comes Queen
side castles and now how do you how do
you play this there are some games that
reach this position where Queen day if I
was played because you really don't want
your queen on the D file but in this
game Queen the B6 was played and it is
now as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game and now look at this
um Mike continues developing Knight to
F3 uh sorry not Knight to F3 uh Bishop
to C4 freeing up the the D file for The
Rook uh and now comes Bishop to D7 it
doesn't matter if black plays Bishop to
E7 tries castling King side uh the
result would be pretty much the same but
in the game Bishop to D7 was played now
we have Knight to F3 and here Queen side
Castle so I don't know decides that she
will cast for Queen side and everything
should be perfectly fine now she
snatched upon she Castle her King to
safety if she can get some developing
moves in uh she's gonna be uh completely
fine even though okay how do you get the
the King off of this uh
C8 Square you would really like him in
the corner but that's not happening
anytime soon you can't kick away the
Knight you can't really put anything on
D6 the white controls D6 and here white
has a couple of ways to actually win the
game and Mike does it in the in the
coolest way possible so feel free to
pause the video and try to figure out
what you played while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this wild
idea and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Rook to D6
that's right you offer the rook and uh
black can't really decline this if black
declines this it's going to be even
worse to give you an example uh you
don't really have any squares for the
queen you could put the queen on A5 but
it is just uh you know black can resign
right away look at this Knight captures
an A7 check King to B8 you have to go
under the mask of the bishop if you go
King to C7 it's even worse Rook C6 is
made in one so you're gonna have to play
King to B8 and now Rook captures on A6
opens up a discovery forces the king in
the corner and after King day eight you
pick up the queen and now once the
Knight moves it's gonna be Checkmate um
well black can go up some material to be
checkmated in a few moves but basically
it's mating one once the Knight moves uh
so that's what happens if you decline
The Rook so there's nothing uh to do but
to accept it Bishop captures on D6 and
now Knight captures and 6 forces the
king under the mask of the bishop King
to B8 and now what do you play well
there are a couple of ways you could
play this but first in Bishop captures
an A6 and the problem is there's no good
way to capture the bishop if you uh if
you capture it with the queen then the
problem is just Knight the B5 check and
now look at this King to C8 You're Gonna
Play Queen E5 and uh black is getting
Checkmate it doesn't really matter what
you do and the other way to capture the
bishop is the capture with the pawn but
now you are within the reach of the
Knight just Knights the C4 check picks
up the queen and that's it there's no
defending this so for the moment the
bishop cannot be captured here anamaya
finds a great defensive move she plays
Knight to D5 and now if white is a bit
Hasty for example white wants to
continue right away let's say Knight to
C4 or opens up a discovery on the queen
and delivers check to the king then the
idea was Knight captures on F4 and to
attack the White Queen and now of course
if you capture the Queen White Queen
comes off with check and that's pretty
much and there there's really not much
you can do even if you play Queen to E5
uh instead of this uh Knight captures
even if you try Queen to E5 check first
then Queen to C7 and black defense uh
with uh material advantage so that's why
after this Knight the D5 move which is a
good defensive idea uh Bishop to E5 and
now you really don't have any uh any
other options
um uh as uh the the the Knight will not
be able to capture the bishop with check
so here Queen captures an A6 offers a
queen trade but now black is just down
too much uh Knight captures on F7 opens
up a discovery here King the A8 and now
Queen captures an A6 getting rid of the
uh the Queen's B captures and not Knight
captures on h8 winning back material
Rook caps and h8 and now Bishop captures
on G7 this is also a very nice Pawn grab
because you don't have to worry about
Rook to G8 captures on G2 as white would
trap The Rook uh so now Rook G8 Bishop
to E5 which means that that if the pawn
is captured just let's say Rook captures
on G2 Bishop G3 and then the next move
you will have the part with the Rook
you'll have to give up the exchange so
after Bishop E5 Bishop to C6 putting
Bishop on this beautiful diagonal but
now just Bishop back to G3 and here you
have this situation where the material
is almost equal white is up upon but as
you can see white has a perfect Pawn
structure two point Islands nothing to
worry about uh Black's Pawn structure is
completely shattered it's only down by
uh the position is done by a pawn you
know in White's favor but four point
islands with a double day pawn this is
completely winning for white and now
it's only a matter of how how to
actually win this Knight to B6 now the
Knight cannot move as the G2 Pawn would
hang so how do you fix this Rook to E1
you go after the E Pawn and now after
Bishop to D5 A3 uh taking care of this
threat but we have Pawn to see four by
black now trying to ruin white spawn
structure by playing C3 and now Knight
to D4 offering the G2 Pawn for the uh
for for the E6 Pawn Rook the G6
defending and now point the F4 preparing
to completely shatter Black's dreams and
hopes with Pawn to F5 we have Knight to
D7 and now Pawn to F5 beautifully played
here uh we have e characters and F5 and
now the Rook also comes into the game
now The Rook will control the seventh
Rank and we all know why they called The
Rook on the seventh rank a pig because
it just gobbles up everything so King to
B7 Rook to E7 now attacks the Knight
King to C8 and not Knight captures on F5
we have Pawn to C3 trying to ruin white
spawn structure just beat captures on C3
it's not a problem because it's an extra
pawn bishop captures and G2 and now Rook
to E2 this is a wonderful idea of how to
trade down into a completely winning end
game because you really want your E7
Square for the for the Knight and now
with the bishop and G2 you have a
perfect square for The Rook so and you
could also play Knight to H4 just attack
the rook and the bishop this also works
but Rook to E2 is fine uh Bishop to F3
attacks The Rook Rook E3 now further
harasses the bishop and Knight the E7 is
coming if you don't want to be down a
full piece so Bishop G4 Knight the E7
check King to B7 and now Knight captures
on G6 H captors and now Rook to E4 now
of course it's even more winning for
white because not only is white up a
pawn white is also have the exchange so
Bishop to F5 and now Rook the B4 with
check King C6 uh Bishop to F2 now going
after one more pawn pawn to A5 and now
Rook to B1 you could put the Rook pretty
much anywhere but there will be one also
works Knight Knight the E5 uh Bishop
captures an A7 and now Knight to C4 so
uh it's a beautiful Square for the
Knight you can't really kick it away
with the Rook you can't touch it with
the bishop because it's on a light
square but the White's position is just
so much better uh even with this
beautiful Knight there's nothing to be
done so A4 uh by white we have Knight
the A3 attacking The Rook but just Rook
the B6 with check King to C7 and now
Rook to F6 preparing H4 H5 to weaken the
bishop on F5 King to D7 and now Pawn to
H4 and okay you could maybe go King The
King to E7 to try and harass The Rook
but that would be terrible if you tried
this to sort of uh make the Rook move
then you run into root captures on F5
and of course the king and Knight are on
dark squares you have to always be
careful about that especially if your
opponent only has a dark Square Bishop
you should really be careful what you
put on dark squares so Knights the C4
the Knight first has to move but now
just H5 and that's pretty much it King
E7 was played Bishop to D4 defending the
rook and here uh Anna Maya Kazarian
resigned as there is absolutely nothing
more to be done in this game uh you
can't attack the bishop you can't go
after any pawns the bishop and King
completely blocked the knight from going
after the A4 Pawn uh you you can't
capture because the bishop hangs if you
do nothing then white will just Advance
the pawn and win the game so there is
absolutely nothing to be done here or
you can even capture and then Advance
the Jeep one doesn't really matter so it
was in this position on move 45 that uh
on a Kazarian resigned and what a what a
wonderful victory for for Mike Catman uh
which I'm very very certain I'm
pronouncing uh very poorly but what are
you gonna do uh but yeah I mean this
position uh here when uh the the black
king castle and this Rook to D6 moved
really really a wonderful way uh
definitely a way to play in the in the
style of Carlos leifter just going all
out and uh eliminating your opponent
very very quickly or or losing but you
you did go all out uh so definitely
fitting of a schlechta variation against
the French defense uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I don't
know if I mentioned it but yeah for
those of you who enjoy and like
Christmas you know Merry Christmas hope
you hope you have a great time with your
family and that you know you you cherish
what matters most in life and uh you
know that you uh have a great rest of
the year and then of course a good
result will come on the board and off
the board so once again really hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
David grosski and Theodore Scott melis
Jack Schroeder and David Kimura for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
you wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World at the
world rapid and Blitz championship
starts very very soon uh thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day